YO !
Alors moi je suis plutôt un rétrogamer, plus à base de Final Fantasy, Mega Man, Crash Bandicoot...
J'ai tout connu moi en jeux vidéo, alors faut pas me chercher moi !
Ah si, j'ai fait du tennis aussi une fois sur la Wii.
The last of us, Batman, Assassin's Creed...
Je suis nul.
Vraiment, mon expérience est au niveau de zéro.
Il paraît que je vais devoir battre mes petits camarades.
Petits camarades, c'est pas moi qui l'ai inventé, on m'a vraiment briefé comme ça.
Bah je vais affronter mes petits camarades, au jeu dont j'ai oublié le nom.
Rush of blood !
Je n'ai aucune idée de ce que ça veut dire.
Bouillon de sang. Non.
Mais il faut tuer des gens, c'est ça ?
Oh malheureux, faut mettre les dragonnes, attends ! On va péter la télé.
Vraiment les gars, ça fait un petit truc.
Quand t'es passé de la Game Gear à ça, ça fait très bizarre.
Attends !
Qu'est-ce qu’il faut faire ?
Attendez, là c'est le truc qui fait peur ?
Rien que les panneaux ils me font flipper !
Oh là là, non mais j'aime pas, je vais tuer des gens.
Oh putain, il m'a fait peur l'enculé !
Je pense qu'il me dit un truc du genre « Bienvenue dans ce train fantôme ! ».
Attends c'est débile, mes bras ils sont comme ça quand je fais comme ça, et l'inverse.
Ah !
Oh je suis chaud !!!
Rien que ça c'est très flippaaaant !
Hé les gars, c'est tellement bien fait, c'est ouf !
C'est mieux que Disneyland.
Hé, je fais "Another one bites the dust".
Ah ok, y'a pas assez de... Ok.
J'ai trop peur,
je peux pas, j'ai trop peur.
Je peux le faire, mais il faut que je vois le réel.
Il faut que je le mette un peu bancale, genre comme ça.
Non parce que là vous m'avez menti, c'est le jeu qui fait peur celui-là !
Est-ce que vous pouvez me parler un peu ?
On est là, on te rassure.
Ok ! Oh putain c'est juste le temps de chargement.
J'ai eu peur du temps de chargement !
Bah salut toi, t'as pas l'air en forme.
Ah bah oui t'es reparti.
Ok, un petit moonwalk.
Faut vraiment que je les tue les gens, je suis obligée, sinon je suis  menacée ou pas ?
Oh merde !
Putain !!!
Ok, tout va bien, je suis terrorisé putain.
Non, tu fais flipper !
Ah ! Ta mère la pute !
C'est horrible putain !
Aaaaah ! Il est derrière caché !
Ah bah ouais, c'est ça mais comment...
Oh putain !
Oh le stress !
J'ai peur d'éclairer un truc et que d'un coup il y ait une tête.
Alors non, ça va pas arriver.
Ils sont déjà passés les bonshommes, les premiers bonshommes ?
Eclaire sur ta gauche, parce que y a peut-être un bonhomme.
L'autre gauche.
Mais pourquoi ça n'éclaire pas bien chez elle ?
Allez, c'est bon j'arrête !
J'ai même pas vu !
Ouah ! Mais qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est une véritable porcherie ici.
Nickel,
ça me donne envie de bouffer du bacon.
C'est clairement pas pour les vegans.
Faut tirer sur les cibles, là.
Je fais un score de merde en fait.
J'ai rien compris au jeu.
Ah des étoiles rouges, bah voilà.
Je suis absolument à l'aise, qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Oh putain !
Y'a des cochons de partout, ça saigne.
Bah ouais, il t'arrive quoi sale porc !
Et je dois tirer sur les étoiles mais ça crie fort, y a des espèces de... Oh putain !
Mais y a plus de... y a plus de lumière ! Ah non non !
Ça va être horrible, ça va être horrible, je ferme les yeux.
Ah, ta mère !
Mais putain !
Niquez-vous !
Niquez-vous tous !
Putain de ta mère !
Ah non mais c'est horrible, c'est horrible, je suis extrêmement stressé, et j'ai envie de chier.
Oh le petit roller coaster de bas étage.
C'est un peu un mix entre Donkey Kong Country, vous vous rappelez, dans la mine ? Et Blair Witch.
Ça ça va, ça c'est Disney, je connais.
Mais j'ai même la sensation du coeur qui remonte.
J'ai vraiment la gerbe.
J'ai l'impression que le siège il est en train de bouger.
Oh là là, tout fait flipper putain, c'est dingue !
Je transpire, là.
Ecoute, cette maison en loi carrez ça doit faire un bon 75, je vais pas la prendre.
C'est carrément... Ah !
Il faut tirer que sur ceux... Hé oh hé dis donc !
Bah ils m'envoient toute la vaisselle !
Il pleut. Oh y a des humains, y a des clowns, non !
Putain c'est quoi ?
Quand tu mettais tes mains tu touchais le micro.
Ah c'est ça ?! Putain mais j'ai eu peur !
Mon score est de 20275.
23185.
Moi j'espère juste avoir battu le record.
18060.
17000.
20605.
J'ai fait 18170.
2 225 000, arrête de mentir !
C'est génial, on en prend plein la gueule,
je me suis pris pour un super héros, pour un cow boy, pour tout ce que tu veux.
C'est une tuerie.
Ça fait super peur, enfin j'ai sursauté réellement.
Je suis pas la cible.
Ça ne provoque rien en moi.
Je déteste.
C'est la pire expérience de ma vie.
C'est hyper immersif.
Mais c'est horrible.
Y a 7 litres de sueur sur ce casque.
Moi ce qui me plaît dans les jeux vidéo, c'est le fait que ce soient des jeux, et que ce soit pas réel quoi.
Là c'est trop réel.
C'est Black Mirror, quoi.
Je déteste.